روسيا تحضر لاستخدام
أكبر مدفع في ترسانة أسلحتها
وأوكرانيا تستنجد ..
والجيش الروسي يضرب الحدود البولندية
والمساعدات الأوروبية والقوات الدولية
في أوكرانيا وحلف الناتو يتوعد ويهدد...
حرب الأسلحة البيولوجية
والكيميائية تقترب،
فمن ينقذ العالم من دمار سيجوب أنحاءه؟
وهنا يظهر قلق أمريكا والناتو،
فماذا لو قررت روسيا استخدام تلك الأسلحة؟
فتظهر وساطة قطرية لمحاولة تهدئة
الدب الروسي لكن هل يستطيع القطريون
فعل مالم تستطعه دول العالم جميعها؟
وزيلينسكي يقترب أكثر من طاولة موسكو
بعد أن تركه الغرب ليلقى مصيره،
فهل يقبل الرئيس الأوكراني بالشروط الروسية؟
وبعد أن عجزت أمريكا عن ثني روسيا
عن الغزو ها هي اليوم تحاول الضغط على حليف
موسكو الأكبر بكين، فهل يرضخ التنين الصيني
للمطالب الغربية يا ترى؟،
وهنا يظهر ترامب ويقول
لو كنت لا أزال رئيسا لأمريكا
لما تجرأ بوتين على هذه الحرب،
(فلتعد يارجل! وأرنا أقصى ما تستطيع فعله)...
المتحدث باسم الخارجية الأمريكية:
نحن قلقون من احتمال استخدام بوتين للأسلحة الكيمائية
في أوكرانيا..
(حرب بيولوجية تهدد البشرية)
ويبقى أهم سؤال يسأله الغرب والعالم حاليا
وهو هل ستتطور المعارك في أوكرانيا
إلى حرب بيولوجية أو كيميائية؟
ما هي هذه الأسلحة التي ترعب العالم؟
الأسلحة الكيميائية هي نوع من الذخيرة
تحمل سموما أو مواد كيميائية تهاجم أجهزة الجسم،
وتستخدم في الحروب على شكل قنابل أو قذائف
مدفعية أو صواريخ لكنها جميعها محظورة
عالميا بموجب اتفاقيات عالمية،
أما الأسلحة البيولوجية:
فهي نوع من الفيروسات أو البكتيريا
أو أحد سمومها يستخدم لنشر مسببات
الأمراض الفتاكة ولكنها أيضا محظورة دوليا
أشهر الأسلحة الكيمائية:
غاز الأعصاب، غاز السارين، غاز الخردل،
غاز الفوسجين..
أشهر الأسلحة البيولوجية:
الجمرة الخبيثة، سم البوتولينيوم، فيروس إيبولا
بعثة ديبلوماسية قطرية تصل موسكو
لبدء محادثات للوساطة في الأزمة الأوكرانية،
وزير خارجية قطر:
نؤمن بالديبلوماسية وأتطلع لمناقشة
مسارات المفاوضات الأوكرانية..
لافروف: نقدر اهتمام دولة قطر ونشكرها على جهودها..
قال المتحدث باسم الكرملين  ديمتري بيسكوف:
"لا أحد يستثني احتمال عقد لقاء مباشر بين بوتين
وزيلينسكي، إلا أن من الضروري قبل ذلك
أن يكون واضحاً ومحدداً ما الذي ستجري مناقشته
بين الرئيسين، وما هي النتائج التي يمكن التوصل إليها".
(زيلينسكي يرضخ)
بينما أكد زيلينسكي في كلمة مصورة
عبر "إنستغرام" أن اللقاء المحتمل "
يجب أن يتركز على النتائج الحقيقية"،
مضيفًا: "من الواضح أن هذه قصة صعبة،
طريق صعب، لكن هذا الطريق مطلوب،
وهدفنا هو أن تحصل أوكرانيا على النتيجة
الضرورية في هذا الصراع،
في هذا العمل التفاوضي، الضروري للسلام وللأمن".
أحد أهم القناصين في العالم، القناص الكندي والي
أوكرانيا استقطبت أكثر من 20 ألف شخص أجنبي
من 52 دولة للمساعدة على القتال ضد روسيا.
ويأتي من ضمن المقاتلين الأجانب،،
والي وهو اسم مستعار لجندي كان في صفوف
نخبة الفوج الملكي الـ 22 التابع للجيش الكندي.
ولكن لا ننسى أيضا أن القناص فاسيلي
كان روسيا وهناك قد يختبئ في الجيش الروسي
ألف فاسيلي،  وكان فاسيلي قد قضى لوحده
على أكثر من  ٢٢٥ جندي نازي ألماني..
(الأحداث والتطورات)
روسيا تستهدف قاعدة عسكرية على الحدود
الأوكرانية البولندية في تصعيد خطير جدا،،
ليخرج عمدة لفيف، مناشدا الرئيس الأمريكي
التدخل لفرض حظر جوي
بعدما وصل القصف إلى الحدود مع دول الناتو
حسب وصفه..
المدفع (إم مالكا ٢٨٧)
أكبر سلاح مدفعي روسي يدخل أرض المعركة،،،
بهدف تدمير المدن الأوكرانية لإجبارها على الاستسلام،
ويمكن لهذا المدفع أن يقضي على مناطق حضرية كبيرة،،
ويحتوي المدفع على قذائف نووية تكتيكية
وقذائف خارقة للخرسانة، وربما قذائف كيماوية..
حذرت الولايات المتحدة من أن الصين
ستواجه "تبعات" قاسية إذا ساعدت روسيا
في غزوها لأوكرانيا، بحسب ما نقلته وسائل إعلام
أمريكية.
سوليفان:
نعتقد أن الصين كانت على علم قبل غزو أوكرانيا
بأن بوتين يخطط لأمر ما..
بحسب ما نقلت رويترز، إن سوليفان سيجري
مقابلة في روما مع يانغ جيه تشي أكبر دبلوماسي صيني،
وسيحذر من العزلة التي قد تواجهها بكين
على الصعيد العالمي إذا استمرت في دعم موسكو.
من جانبها، تفادت الصين تأكيد مزاعم الغرب
نحو روسيا حتى إشعار آخر..
الناتو يحذر روسيا من استخدام الأسلحة الكيمائية
وإن تعرضت إحدى الدول الأعضاء في الحلف
لأي ضرر يعبر من الحدود الأوكرانية
فسيرد الحلف بكامل قوته...
مشاهد لرئيس الشيشان رمضان قديروف
في أوكرانيا وهو يدير المعارك من غرفة عمليات..
وقال قديروف أنه يدير العمليات من مطار
غوستوميل القريب من العاصمة كييف، ،
وعلى الجنود الأوكران الاستسلام
وإلا فسينتهي أمرهم بحسب تعبيره
بينما تقول موسكو أنها قتلت ١٨٠ من المرتزقة
الأجانب في يافوريف، بعد أن كانت قد هددت
سابقا بقطع إمدادات الأجانب
ترد السلطات الأوكرانية، بأن حصيلة ضحايا
القصف الروسي على قاعدة تدريب عسكرية
قرب مدينة لفيف، ارتفع  إلى 35 قتيلاً
و 134 جريحاً.
ترامب لو كنت رئيسا لما تجرأ بوتين على إعلان الحرب
الرئيس الأمريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
يتهم الرئيس الحالي جو بايدن بالفشل
بردع الحرب الروسية على أوكرانيا،
ويقول أن الحرب ما كانت لتندلع لو كان هو الرئيس
الموجود في البيت الأبيض
(يجب على الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
أن توضح لبوتين أن أمامه خيارين،
إما التفاوض على السلام في الوقت الحالي
أو سيواجه عواقب وخيمة،
بما في ذلك الضغط من أجل القضاء نهائيا
على الاعتماد على الطاقة الروسية)
الجيش الروسي  يعلن قتل (مرتزقة أجانب )
وتدمير معدات أجنبية بضربات دقيقة في أوكرانيا..
الاشتباكات كثيفة في إيربن وهناك قتل صحفي أمريكي
يعمل في نيويورك تايمز، وجرح آخر ،،
ليخرج بعدها رئيس بلدية إيربن ويعلن
منع الصحفيين من الدخول إلى هذه المنطقة..
سوليفان: سنرد بشكل مناسب على قتل روسيا
لصحفي أمريكي في أوكرانيا
قالت الدفاع البريطانية: فرضت حصارا
على كل سواحل أوكرانيا في البحر الأسود،
وتشن ضرباتها الصاروخية على أهداف
بكل أنحاء أوكرانيا..
صربيا تعتبر البوابة الأخيرة لروسيا للهروب
من العقوبات الغربية، بحظر الطيران،
فهي دولة لها حدود مع ٨دول
وتجمعها جذور ثقافية مشتركة مع روسيا. وكانت
صربيا قد رفضت العقوبات الغربية على روسيا،
بينما ضاعفت الرحلات بينها وبين روسيا
إلى ١٥ رحلة أسبوعيا،  لتكون بذلك
هي الملاذ لروسيا للسفر إلى دول العالم
زيلينسكي: القوات الروسية قصفت بعض قوافل
المساعدات الإنسانية...
ووزارة الدفاع الروسيه تنفي ذلك وتقول
إنها استهدفت عتاد عسكري وأسلحة  قادمة
من الدول الغربية
زيلنسكي يقترب أكثر نحو الدب الروسي
فهل تعلن أوكرانيا استسلامها
أم أنها مجرد مفاوضات لإطالة الحرب فقط؟
....